um I just saw uh J Prince was uh out in
Saudi Arabia with Vince McMahon and
Kanye at the fight what your
relationship these days like with J
Prince oh that's my guy that's my guy uh
like I said um in other interviews I
appreciate him I appreciate everything
that he done for me um he's he he's
family to me so um
I I got nothing but good things to say
about Jay uh I appreciate him yeah when
you go to Houston are you just like do
you get the red carpet yeah for sure go
to htown yeah have you been to Onyx out
there Onyx uh good place I don't know
establishment I don't remember if I've
been there or not I was just there a few
days ago we we uh we went hog hunting
hog hunting yeah with this rapper
there's a rapper out there named Mexican
OT and he took us hog hunting in a
helicopter we were like hanging out the
side of a IOP bro I swear to God we were
hanging out the side of a helicopter
with AR-15 shooting
pigs by the way they're Pest and their
invasive species so in my mind I felt
like I was you know helping helping
Farmers out you know what I'm saying n i
I've done it before but you've done that
not in no helicopter but you killed the
pigs no I shot at them I ain't I a i i a
hit nothing n oh but you did it in Texas
yeah oh so you did you did what did you
have the night vision goggles yeah oh
yeah so yeah we did that too yeah yeah
for sure you sure you didn't hit nothing
n I'm sure I ain't hit nothing buto you
had the goggles you got the scop I'm
sure I didn't hit that you missed on
purpose you're a good man n it was like
a uh they was farther down I smoked them
they wasn't uh as close yeah no it was
fun it was like I felt like I was in
like with the night goggles at cuz we
did the helicopter and then we did the
nighttime [__] I felt like I was in Call
of Duty and then they were near some
cows and they were like you know they
could kill those cows I was like not yet
cuz I'mma kill them first sa save some
Cattle Man this dude crazy um yo um yo
talk obviously you're you're real tight
with bud with Terence Crawford
um how you feeling about a rematch
between him and
Spence uh my honest opinion on it um I
think that Errol is a great fighter I
think that um he's tough and and he got
the Heart of a Lion for even wanting to
do a rematch with but but but um my
honest opinion I don't want to see it
like I wouldn't want to watch the first
fight was so like definitive yeah that
it was like it be you know it wasn't
like it was just too one-sided exactly
yeah like if it was more so like a
competitive fight then it'll be like
okay I like to see it but it wasn't like
competitive enough for me to like want
to watch it again but that's just my
opinion on I don't want nobody take it
the wrong way but um I don't want to see
it so you're fighting uh Edwin de los
Santos yes
um I don't know who the hell this guy is
so I'm assuming that you're going to
beat the living [__] out of this guy
yeah n but he's he's a good fighter I'm
going to put it out there and say U I
watched him uh he got good boxing skills
um you got to respect your opponent at
all times man no no he's a good fighter
though know what I'm saying but you have
to like I feel like sometimes we see our
like boxers popping [__] in press
conferences and I'm like yo man like
this guy's still professional there's a
reason why he's fighting so this guy's
good what I'm saying is you just got to
be aware of who you're in the ring with
sometimes and being aware of that you
don't want to sleep on nobody sleeping
on that dude would be like the wrong
move for me to make so um this dude is a
great boxer puncher and um you could
tell that he's hungry and he's going to
come to win so uh for sure I I respect
him as a a fighter but he's just going
against the best he's going against the
best and I'm sure all the money in Vegas
is on you so yeah for sure yeah I always
wonder cuz you know I used to live in
Vegas and betting on fights was so much
fun do you ever like think to yourself
like if I lose people are eating [__] at
the sports book hell no nah I ain't
thinking like that um I'm Type fighter
I'll be so confident that I'll go bet on
myself oh that is that allowed uh I mean
if you do it the right way yeah Floyd
used to do that yeah I don't I don't
know I think I don't know uh can you go
to the casinos and do it but I can one
time I interviewed 50 set when I was
living in Vegas and Floyd was fighting
that week 50 had a million dollars in a
backpack he brought it to the radio
station he's like I'm about to take this
across the street put it on Floyd I said
damn he's like for Floyd but I I I did
that and I lost before cuz I had bet on
the um knockout and one you lost money
on yourself man I lost like uh I want to
say 15,000 of myself so you bet you were
going to knock him out yes cuz it was it
was a fight that they didn't think I was
going to knock him out which fight was
this it was um against Robson C and
that's why the whole fight like my
coaches like they telling me like chill
chill chill like the whole fight in your
head you're like I gotta win this money
I'm about to knock this [__] out
that's all I was thinking of like I'm
trying to get the knockout but they
telling me like yo just box your way
into it I'm like no forget what y'all
talking about we about to lay him out
I'm going to get him like we about to
take yeah what do you know what the what
the payout would have been cuz I'm sure
the odds had to be positive uh I don't
remember what the payout was but I know
I bet like 15 B on me stopping that dude
before like the for that's so F and I
was so mad that I didn't yo I love that
dude